you're all Walker Texas Ranger it's like
a pretty cool Walker Independence you
know why you would like his character
for some of the series he has like an
Asian accent but it's fake
save enough money learn enough English
to uh start a business here it's a sick
ass reveal I gotta watch it to save this
town
so your accent's not real either it's
hard because you grow up doing the
accident making fun of it and then it's
like I'm trying to do it so that people
aren't laughing at it I can't do that
I'm from China that's the Jeremy Lin
doing math Jeremy Lin doing math is not
good for the show okay momentum two eggs
of Plaza Infinity
if someone watched Walker and was like
wait a minute the director was like hold
on that reminds me of something hold on
don't tell me don't tell me it was
actually sort of my idea to make it so
he had the backstory that he was faking
it because in the beginning of the show
like that wasn't in the script yeah that
much power on set the writer's room is
pretty open suggestions is that why the
show got canceled previously on Walker
Independence